dizaines d'étudiants gabonais a fait
irruption dans la salle ils étaient
venus dénoncer le soutien à ali bongo
nicolas sarkozy lorsqu'il était à
l'elysée
quand j'ai entendu nos ancêtres les
gaulois comme on dit chez moi ça pue
plus rien on fait jamais
allez
la campagne à droite est officiellement
lancée et certains des salles candidat
retenu pour la primaire se montre déjà
très matinaux c'est donc à 6h34 qu'alain
juppé décide d'envoyer ce tweet très
lapidaire nullité du débat politique que
soulève certains à droite et à gauche on
débat des gaulois et si on parlait
d'avenir
si vous voulez parler du gabon retourner
si vous êtes à l'aise avec ça vous savez
aujourd'hui on est devant une france qui
est extrêmement fracturée avec des
problèmes qui sont des problèmes très
importants notamment des problèmes de
migration ces sujets là ne peuvent pas
faire l'objet de tabou il avec ni sur la
table nicolas sarkozy a choisi de
rechercher le succès électoral par la
division du pays en obsédant les
français sur le l'origine sur les
gaulois sur l'identité sur les ans est
alain juppé parle de nullité débat
politique ce matin bleu je crois que le
mot tu es juste qu'il avait regretté la
nullité du débat politique sur twitter
très récemment oui je persiste le seuil
dominique pour moi faire campagne c'est
pas lâcher une incongruité tous les
jours pour faire parler de soi vous
lâcher je cite une incongruité par jour
je ne polémiquerai pas ni avec juppé ni
qui que ce soit dire les autres sont
nuls
c'est classique j'aime ce que des à part
dont c'est ce que dit tout le monde et
ça ne fait pas avancer le débat je suis
certain qu alain avec les grandes
qualités qui sont les siennes
vanu redressa nous redresser ce à lui
tout seul je lui fais confiance
après moi je souhaite que mon pays
fassent la démonstration il est capable
d'accueillir 9000 je ne pas pas d'un
million je ne parle pas de 100000 je ne
parle pas de 50000 9000 réfugiés de
calais nous n'aurions pas nous la
capacité d'accueillir dans nos villes et
dans nos quartiers ceux qui demandent
l'asile et qui fuient aujourd'hui la
guerre de la syrie ou en irak
ap